for a lot of us the cancellation of
silent Hills last year felt like a stake
to the heart pt 2 ps4 exclusive
precursor offered a tantalizing glimpse
into what Hideo Kojima creator of the
Metal Gear series and guillermo del toro
renowned film director were capable of
when pairing together even though silent
Hills is dead that doesn't mean the duo
has permanently parted ways at this
year's dice awards a pair will give the
keynote address titled a conversation
with hideo kojima in Guillermo del Toro
according to the event organisers the
pair will share insight into their
respective creative visions and
processes Jeff kelia games media veteran
who organizes the game awards will
moderate the discussion this
conversation will revisit some of their
fondest memories from their own
individual careers as well as some of
the pivotal moments from each other's
work that remain a constant source of
inspiration in addition Kojima will be
inducted into the academy of interactive
arts and sciences Hall of Fame at the
event later this month Padilla and ultra
have said they are interested in working
together on something new where no
collaborations have been officially
announced the 18th annual dice awards
will take place on februari 18th and if
anything comes out of it stay tuned to
gamespot com for all the latest info